hello everyone and happy new year
everyone uh we are starting 2021 with a
with a pretty crazy game between the
neil dubovo and temur rajabov uh it's
the
second match of their semi-final match
rajabo won the first match by
winning games three and four and now
dubo needs to win this match to bonds
back and then
take it into tie break so what will he
do and will he be able to do it uh let's
check it out
so without further ado do of with the
white pieces opens with
knight to f3 so he goes for the retti
opening
we have knight to f6 and now c4
uh we have e6 by black uh and now knight
to c3
we have d5 uh and now d4 and now we've
basically transposed into the queen's
gambit declined and here bishop to e7
and now uh as dooba lost the previous
match he needs to
really win this one and even though
there are plenty of moves you can play
here
bishop g for the most popular one bishop
to f or c captures and e5
all very popular moves double goes for
the most uh most aggressive
one so uh the barbarian king king
strikes again
uh g4 just offering that uh that pawn
here but
uh you do not capture this pawn because
it simply allows
white too much play if the pawn is
captured you get rook g1
and already black will be struggling so
instead uh
rajabo just castles to safety and here
g5
immediately attacking that knight knight
to e4
and now uh bishop to g2 is a new move
here but uh the position has been
reached before it's been played in 2010
between mamedyarov
and uh ponomariov uh where queen the c2
was played but
this g4 g5 is not uh nothing new so it
was played um
in top tier games and nakamura is well
employed it
so here bishop to g2 by do both and it
is now only as of move seven that we
have a completely new game
so uh as it's very uh principled when
you're attacked on the king side you
want to counter attack in the center as
duvo's king is still in the center of
the board so this is what rajab does he
strikes the center with c5
uh with the captures on c5 and now
knight
captures on c3 b captures and bishop
captures on c5 so
exchanging in the center and preparing
the captures on c4 to offer a queen
trade
uh duba continues uh launching those
pawns on the king side with h4
and now knight to c6 by the job of with
h5
and now d captures in c4 grabbing upon
and offering a queen trade
uh dubo doesn't want to trade he plays
queen to c2 he wants to attack somehow
and now e5 and you can see that there's
a
there's a a a lot of possibilities here
for white how do you continue here you
really want to push those pawns but for
the moment it's not really all that
great for example if h6 g6
uh you're never going to be able to
exploit this diagonal since your own
pawn is blocking any any endeavors you
might have here
along this um uh diagonal so
after this e5 we have rook to b1 and not
allowing the light square bishop to be
developed as the b pawn would hang
so here bishop to b6 by doing this you
cannot develop your light square
bishop but on the on the other hand you
uh
let go of this diagonal so bishop to a3
will always be an idea
uh instead of just this bishop to b6
idea you could also go for a very
aggressive f5 this was also a
possibility
and then if g captures queen captures
and black gets a lot of development here
and there's going to be a lot of
pressure along this f file
but okay instead we have bishop to b6
and now comes
knight to h4 dub of waiting with that
bishop to a3 move so knight here he
wants to bring the knight to f5 and the
knight will be a really strong piece
there
uh black might have to give up the light
square bishop to take care of it so here
uh rajab instead goes for f5 right away
now he takes control of the f5 square
and he says
now my position is great whatever you
push i'm just going to push
the other pawn and uh well you can also
capture alpassang
but it's not going to be all that great
because i get to develop my pieces
but there's not much else to be done
like i said you could go bishop to a3
uh but dubo still awaits with that move
so he does capture it
g captures an f6 and the queen captures
and now there's a lot of pressure along
the f file so you have to do something
about that dual place e3
and now bishop to e6 rojava continues
developing his pieces and now
bishop to e4 and here adobo is attacking
that h7 pawn now hoping
that rajab will make some sort of a
weakness here with h6 then
uh you can all you can have all sorts of
ideas bishop h7 check the knight can
come to g6
uh a lot of moves are possible here but
rajabov plays the absolute best queen to
h6 which prevents
the bishop captures but also prevents
white uh from pushing the h
pawn and here the black's position is
great but uh rajabov is very low on time
he has some two and a half minutes on
the clock whereas
dubo has over five minutes and only now
bishop to a3
challenging that rook so rook to f7 and
now
queen to e2 guarding that h5 pawn not
allowing black to capture it we rook to
d8 now uh rajab mobilized all of his
pieces
and rook the g1 uh and here
although it seems like white is
attacking it's actually black who has a
really really awesome move but it's
really hard to spot the movies actually
bishop to a5
uh just going for that c3 pawn and it's
incredibly hard to defend it for example
rook c5 now you just
jump in with rook to d3 and all sorts of
uh
moves uh become possible here it's just
a very crazy position
and uh for example if captures you're
going to capture here with the queen if
queen captures
then you lose control of the h5 pawn you
there are really a lot a lot of threats
here
uh you will be able to uh
like just bust through the position for
example queen captures on h5 you can go
with this
and then you're attacking the knight
everything is hanging it's not going to
be it's not going to be a lot of fun for
white to play this and
that extra material white has it will
not help him all that much
so here instead after rook to g1 uh uh
we did not have bishop to a5 we have
queen to f6 by the job of
now keeping the pressure on the f2 pawn
and now comes
knight to f3 uh so uh the queen can now
move
the knight is defended but also the
knight wants to come to g5 to put
pressure on the rook and the bishop here
and also the h7 pawn
so here bishop to d5 uh rajaba wants to
trade off a pair of bishops and
now bishop captures on d5 and here jabba
was already extremely low on time under
30 seconds but
as i always like to remind you guys uh
they do get a 10 seconds increment after
every move so bishop captures on b5
rook captures and now comes knight to g5
uh attacking the f7 rook and here uh
queen to
f5 rajabo goes after dooba's rook here
again there was the possibility of this
e4 idea which is extremely strong this
e4 move is always in the position
because it simply
frees the e5 square for this knight and
then if the knight comes to d3
or f3 is just going to be excellent for
black
but okay queen f5 going after the rook
uh and here uh
really an awesome idea was possible for
duba
he could have gone for rook captures on
b6 point is that black's rook is still
under attack here and there is this
problem of
e4 e4 doesn't work uh just yet
uh because bishop captures on f2 but if
you capture the bishop first
then black cannot recapture the rook
because if this then just e4
and white wins so this was in the
position for duboff but it's a rapid
game you can't see everything rook to c1
getting the rook out of harm's way and
now rook to f6
black does the same we have rook to g2
now adding another defender here
and now rook to d3 now white no longer
has a light square bishop and this rook
is free to go here and this e4 move is
always in the position
so here queen to g4 offering a queen
trade and now
now we have a very very tricky move by
rajabov feel free to pause the video and
win the game for a job of while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
beautiful rook sacrifice and for those
of you who just won't enjoy the show
it's
rook captures an e3 and now point is if
the rook is captured then it's just
checkmate queen f1 check
you go here queen checks you go here and
rook to f1 will be checkmate
so instead after real characters on on
e3 dual went back into f1
and now we have a queen trade queen
captures rook captures and now
rook back to d3 sorcero accepted the
queen's
queen trade but he grabbed the e3 pawn
uh before doing that and now
the position is just very very difficult
to play for do but he's down two pawns
uh and in in a lesser position so let's
see how he plays this out
rook to c2 and now h6 kicking back the
knight
knight to e4 attacking the rook here and
now rook to f4
offering the rook trade you have to
accept it because the knight hangs so
captures captures
and now king to g2 you do not want to
allow this pawn to come here
then you just constantly have to worry
about ideas like rook to d1 mate
so king to g2 and now rook to d5
rajab goes after the h5 pawn and now
bishop to d6 uh duboff just
also wants to grab some pawns while he's
at it so rook captures an h5
bishop captures on f4 and now rook back
to d5
again what you play here is white it's a
very very difficult position to play we
have rook to e2
and now just kink to h7 ah rajab
improves the position of his king
knight back to d2 and now bishop to a5
finally this bishop to a5 move lands and
now we have
a pawn trait captures captures uh and
now
knight to d6 so going after that b7 pawn
and here uh rojava pushes it to b6 you
could also push it to b5 the rook
defends it and then just continue
pushing
both a and b pawn because black has two
points on the queen side white only has
one
at some point you will push them all the
way and you will trade off that one pawn
and you will get a pass pawn
and ideally win the game so b6
uh a job of taking it slow and now rook
to c2 attacking both of these
uh pieces uh but there are actually
quite a few ways to defend it one of
them being bishop to e5 just extremely
strong
and then whatever you trade uh black
just grabs the other one for or if
bishop captures just knight capture so
it's not really a problem
uh but rajava finds an even sneakier one
knight to d4
a temporary peace sacrifice but he will
recapture it right after
so rook captures it is the best move and
now knight
e2 a nice fork here on the rook and the
bishop
rook to c6 and now just captures with
check
king of three knights the d3 and now
king the e4
again with a double attack but just
knight to b4
attacking and the defending here we have
a3 by double now
trying to remove the defender of the
rook here but
rajabo first uh gives a check on d4 to
kind of
make the the white king lose the tempo
so king captures on d4
knight captures on c6 and now king to d5
uh the king finds its way to d5 all the
same
knights the a5 and now knights the c8
and here
dubo is down two pawns uh but uh he has
a very active king so maybe maybe he can
hold this but
rajava doesn't even care about the a7
pawn he just starts pushing this pawn
and you always have to be careful you
have to be careful that your king is
inside the square of the pawn as long as
it's in there you know that you will
always be able to
catch up to the past pawn so knows this
of course he captures upon as he does
have time
h4 and now king to e4 uh with
knight to c for now attacking the a3
pawn and
king to f for now just going after that
pawn and here
uh is a beautiful position i think this
is the
the greatest position in this game uh
really should
uh you know share this one with your
friends at the bar in the library of
course
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for
rajab with a brilliant seat while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
rajabov's signature move uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
uh it's knight the e5 and this is just
beautiful
the knight covers these two squares the
pawn covers g3
and the king cannot approach the past
pawn and of course you cannot capture
the knight because if you capture the
knight
you are no longer in the square of the
pawn and you will not be able to catch
up to the pawn
black just pushes and wins the game the
problem is
white has no moves here for example if
you just make any move knight c6
g5 is coming with check and now you have
to step back either capture here or here
and then the pass pawn just wins the
game doesn't matter where you go
the pass pawn is winning so really
amazing move knight to the e5 by the
java but he missed it he played the g5
check instead
tried to get the king to capture it so
he can advance his pawn
so king to g4 and only now knight to e5
check also also very strong but the
other one was just
ending the game immediately king h3 and
now king to g6 and now rejabu will
slowly creep in with the king and start
pushing those pawns
uh knight to c8 uh dubois also wants to
create a pass pawn of his own but her
job of defense knight the c4
we have king to g4 not allowing um our
javascript to
come any closer and now b5 we have
f4 the strongest move by double trying
to uh
well get those pawns disconnected but
now knight to e3 with
check and here you have two
possibilities for for
white one is to go king to h3 one is to
go king to f3
one saves the game the other one
blunders the game terribly so
where do you go from here of course you
go king to h3
because you have to keep an eye on this
pawn however however
dubo went king to f3 and now this is a
huge problem because
he allows h3 again you cannot capture
the knight because you will leave the
square of the pawn and it's just game
over
so do now has to waste the move king g3
but now
g4 and the pass pawn is protected and
this is just terrible for do both
uh knight to e7 check king f6
knight the c6 and now knight to f1 with
check we have king to f2 and again h2
the knight cannot be captured because of
h1 queen
soaking back to g2 and then now g3 now
the position is just playing itself
knight to e5
and now comes knight to e3 with check
king h1
and here rojo just played knight to d1
and it was in this position that daniel
dubo resigned the game and
what what a beautiful a beautiful game
to start 2021 with
as uh you know so many things happened
here and it could have gone either way
but rajabo he's just
brilliant he's he's so great at uh
suppressing
dubo's you know attacking prowess
and uh he just doesn't care what's the
time on the clock like
yesterday he was on one second on the
clock like so many moves and then he
just makes a move with one second
on the clock and then he just plays with
increment and here also he was
under 10 seconds at some points in the
game and he just plays uh
strongest replies uh really just crazy
so one of the reasons why uh why his
attacks
don't work against so well as they did
against magnus because magnus
just allowed the duba to do anything
because he knew what he was doing was uh
was
well like the best move but then at some
point
uh he made one little mistake and duba
took advantage of that but yeah here you
resign
uh to show you the quickest way possible
let's say you go on ig for check king f5
white is auto moves knight h6 check king
e4 and now just game over whatever you
play
just knight f2 check that's the point of
knight to d1 you have to go here
and now you can either bring a queen
into the game or just go for checkmate
king f4
beautiful stuff and now after let's say
f6 h1 will be
checkmate so of course the dub of
sawdust and after knight to d1 he
resigned the game
and game two game one of match two goes
to tamora rajabov
and now it's going to be incredibly
difficult for duboff to get back
into the match but we'll see what
happens it's still a few more games to
go
so yeah once again i do hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank uh
dinko galatic
oliver van der sis uh michael selling
andre mendes and tim kruger for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
fine tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and happy new
year once again everyone